Republicans tearing into Homeland
Security secretary Majorca said telling
him it's time to step down this comes
after weeks just weeks after the head of
the border patrol testified that the
administration did not have operational
control of the Southern border
Republican Senators unleashing on the
secretary
let me be clear number one we are
intensely focused on securing the Border
it appears to me to be something that is
perhaps an intentional effort to
obfuscate the real problem to hide the
absolute humanitarian and legal disaster
you haven't been fired you should be
fired we've seen
nothing but death and destruction
as a result if you had Integrity you
would reside and I will tell you the men
and women of the border patrol they've
never had a political leader undermine
them they despise you Mr secretary
because you're willing to let children
be raped
to follow political orders now judge do
you think that was that was hyperbole
was just I mean like we I think we all
agree majorcus is a complete idiot and
he should go but uh do you think what I
just I just wouldn't say his complete
adage just so you said we all oh he is
Jessica I am speaking for you Jessica
said to me in the Green Room
is a complete idiot but I'm saying that
he would let children get raped probably
a little too far well it depends it
depends on the facts I think he is an
evil idiot I think that he is
intentionally not recognizing that
children are being raped many children
are being put on birth control by their
parents as they make the trip there are
rape trees I've seen the panties hanging
from them I've gone to the border at
least four times I know what's going on
from the ranchers from the border patrol
no I don't think that was hyperbole I
think that what is happening where we
allow this this this influx many
children without their parents these
kids have been raped we already have
what is it now 800 uh immigrants who who
are just dead they're they're dead
within the area of the United States
nobody seems to care about them
Americans are dying no one seems to care
about them either we just talked about
Joe Joe fentanyl Joe Biden Joe fentanyl
is better that's what yeah laughing out
the mother who lost two of her sons and
saying oh it was political you know it
was the other guy who's at fault no I
don't think that's hyperbola I think
this guy ought to go he's evil he is
allowing
um all kinds of damage to this nation
and not protecting it I it's treasonous
should I ask a question
um sure what is a rape tree
a rape tree is when you take the panties
of the victim and you hang them from the
tree so they know how many women have
been raped by you oh my God all right
well Jesse I want to ask you about the
fact that uh Trump had been impeached
twice once as covet was taking off under
the assumption that he wasn't going to
be impeached anyway or he wasn't going
anywhere why don't why is it majorcus
being impeached I had just asked Jillian
the same question she says they don't
have the votes I guess you need
two-thirds but put it out there anyway
yes this scar why not waste the time
that they wasted with everybody else it
won't even be is nearly as long as the
Trump impeachment was yeah which one I
don't remember a real journalist would
ask the question is mayork is in
business with the drug cartels because
he has made the drug cartels richer than
they've ever been he is the drug cartel
employee of the year you know they make
more money from Human Trafficking than
from cocaine and what has he done with
human trafficking it's exploded under
his watch is the guy of a fetish for
getting his butt kicked in public every
hearing he knows what's coming he know
Cruz is going to kill him and he comes
to the hearing totally unprepared he has
no idea what statistics he is how many
people how many people oh we're gonna
have to get he's not going to admit it
he knows every answer to every question
okay well I thought he was stupider than
that and he doesn't know what the
bracelets are every Fox viewer knows the
bracelets we've covered it a thousand
times if you don't know that you can't
say you care I just want to know where
the media is you have rape trees you
have the Detention Center that
incinerated migrants the other day you
have fentanyl deaths you have total
chaos they don't cover it but the minute
a republican gets into office they're
going to start covering some migrant
that is missing a blanket and that's the
best part about losing elections you get
to see what the media covers that they
covered up before exactly you know Julie
did they did he yet apologize for the
whip gate where he maligned his own
employees saying that they were whipping
migrants I don't think that's happened
yet
are the majorcus you mean yes DHS or the
Administration has not acknowledged the
findings of the investigation amazing um
how convenient it is a catch-22 now for
the Biden Administration in terms of
trying to
do anything to ameliorate this crisis
because the numbers have been so high
historically high for two years the only
options available to them now policy
wise to try and make a dent are fairly
extreme they run the gamut of things
like reconsidering family detentions
which to the Democrats is like
anathema I mean it's something that they
hammered Trump over for four years they
can't do what Trump did even if it works
well but doing something doing anything
less than that is not going to improve
the situation so if Biden acts it's a
political death now if he doesn't
um the numbers continue to climb there's
no great options anymore last word
Jessica make it valuable
I think it's good that people who even
know that they're being set up to be
criticized like this continue to show up
to your point where you say he just
keeps coming back I think it's important
that the people who serve in our
Administration who are in charge of
these very important aspects of our
country are available
um don't show up I'm saying show up
prepared I
he was prepared but not for that hearing
he doesn't have the bracelets come on he
was prepared for lunch no listen each
Administration has a different story
that they want to tell about what's
going on at the border the Trump
administration had a different story
than the Obama Administration wanted to
tell him the Bush Administration and
that's just how it works unfortunately
but with this particular issue what
makes it different than a lot of other
ones is that it's life or death right
it's life or death for Americans and
it's life or death for the Mexicans and
everyone who's coming from everywhere
else hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else